MORE "THE STORY" BACK HERE.
MY FRIEND TUCKER CARLSON IS
COMING UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT, A DRAFT REPORT BY MEMBERS
OF THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE SAYS THAT THERE IS "NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
COORDINATION OR CONSPIRACY
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
THE RUSSIANS."
THAT IS THE RESULTS OF 14 MONTHS
OF INVESTIGATION.
GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT," THE REPORT WE
JUST REFERRED TO FOUND NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION, SAYS THAT
AMERICA WAS WOEFULLY ON EDUCATED
TO CHECK THE EFFORTS.
IT ALSO BLASTS OUR TOP
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS WERE
LEAKING TO THE MEDIA.
150 PAGE REPORT WILL BE REVIEWED
BY DEMOCRATS AND INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS BEFORE IT IS WHERE THE
LEAST TO THE PUBLIC.
MIKE CONWAY, THE REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTING TEXAS, HE JOINS US
IN THE STUDIO.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: IS THE REPORT AS
DEFINITIVE AS WE SUGGESTED ON
THE QUESTION OF COLLUSION?
>> DAYS.
WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH 73
WITNESSES, LOOKING AT 300 PLUS
THOUSAND DOCUMENTS.
TO TRY TO FIND WHAT THERE MIGHT
BE.
WE HAVE SEEN SOME MEETINGS THAT
WERE INAPPROPRIATE OR
ILL-ADVISED TO HAVE TAKEN AND
SOME CHANCE COINCIDENCES WHERE
PEOPLE BUMP INTO EACH OTHER, BUT
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THE
RUSSIANS OR THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
AND THE RUSSIANS.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SATISFIED
THAT YOU SAW ENOUGH INTELLIGENCE
GATHERED BY THE INTEL AGENCY IS
TO MAKE THAT JUDGMENT?
>> WE MADE THE JUDGMENT BASED ON
THE ON INVESTIGATION OF
WITNESSES, 73 WITNESSES LOOKING
FOR IN THE THREAD THAT WOULD
LEAD US TO A COLLUSION
CONSPIRACY OR COORDINATION.
WE FOUND NO EVIDENCE THAT
ANYTHING LIKE THAT WAS GOING ON.
>> Tucker: ADAM SCHIFF TODAY
WHO WOULD BE THE RANKING
DEMOCRAT FROM THE COMMUNITY
RELEASED THE STATEMENT CALLING
THEIR REPORTS A TRAGIC MILESTONE
THEIR REPORTS A TRAGIC MILESTON
MILESTONE.
HE SAYS IT SHORT-CIRCUITS AN
INVESTIGATION THAT HE IMPLIES IS
JUST GETTING GOING.
>> 14 MONTHS IS NOT JUST GETTING
GOING, LIKE WE HAVE SAID, WE
HAVE DONE MORE TO ANSWER THE
FOUR QUESTIONS, YOU PRETTY
NARROW SCOPE THAT DID NOT
INCLUDE COLLUSION WITH A LOT OF
THINGS, AND MAYBE HE WANTS TO
CHASE IT DOWN, WE HAD FOUR
QUESTIONS TO ANSWER AND WE HAVE
DONE THE RELEVANT INVESTIGATION
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS.
>> Tucker: SO YOU MUST HAVE
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THE STORY
MORE BROADLY.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU DID AFTER THAT
TIME.
YOU SAY THAT THE INTEL AGENCIES
RELEASED THE 17 INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES SAYING THAT TO THE
PUTIN GOVERNMENT FAVORED TRUMP.
AND YOU ARE SAYING THAT IS NOT
CORRECT?
>> FIRST OF ALL IT IS THREE
AGENCIES.
>> Tucker: I AM AWARE, THAT IS
THE TALK.
INCLUDING THE COAST GUARD AND
ALL THE REST.
>> HE WAS TRYING TO PITCH THAT
THOUGHT.
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE NRO HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT.
90% OF WHAT THEY DID ON THE ICA
WE AGREE WITH.
WE HAVE TWO TRADE ANALYSTS GO
THROUGH THAT WITH A FINE TOOTH
COMB, THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS AND THE PIECE ABOUT
TRUMP AND THE PUTIN REPORTED
PREFERENCE FOR TRUMP IS NOT
SUPPORTED BY THE EVIDENCE.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD THEY SAY
THAT?
>> WE HAVE TO ASK THEM, BUT WE
DISAGREE WITH THEM THAT THEY
STARTED IN EARLY DECEMBER AND
WAS FINISHED IN JANUARY.
COINCIDING WITH THE ATTACK ON
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
AND THEY SEEM TO UNDERPIN THAT
NARRATIVE THAT SOMEHOW PUTIN HAD
MORE EFFECT ON THE ELECTION THEN
HE SHOULD HAVE.
THE LEGITIMATE HIGHS AT THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
IT WAS PART OF THAT NARRATIVE.
>> Tucker: TAKEN AT FACE
VALUE, WE ARE REMINDED ON THE
DEMOCRATS OF WHAT IS TRUE,
SOUNDS LIKE A POLITICAL
STATEMENT?
>> 98% OF WHAT THEY DID IS THE
TRADECRAFT, THERE IS TRADE CRAFT
ASSOCIATED WITH ANALYTICS AND
THAT WAS FOLLOWED.
BUT JUST ON THAT ONE PIECE ABOUT
PUTIN'S ALLEGED PREFERENCE FOR
TRUMP WAS NOT SUPPORTED.
>> Tucker: I'VE NEVER BEEN
CLEAR ON THE UNDERLYING
QUESTIONS OF ALL OF THIS WHICH
IS THE HACKING OF THE DNC
SERVERS AND OF JOHN PODESTA AS
GMAIL ACCOUNT, AND I ASKED THE
RANKING DEMOCRAT ADAM SCHIFF
ABOUT THIS AND COULD NOT GET A
STRAIGHT ANSWER.
ARE WE POSITIVE THAT THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT WAS BEHIND STEALING
THAT DATA?
>> ABOUT AS POSITIVE AS YOU CAN
BE WHERE IT IS VERY DIFFICULT,
BUT I AM COMFORTABLE BELIEVING
THAT THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT WAS
BEHIND THE HACKERS THAT DID ALL
OF THIS.
WHETHER THE ENTITIES WERE DOING
IT WORD DONE ABOUT HALF OF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT NOT ON
BEHALF, SO I AM COMFORTABLE
MAKING STATEMENT.
AGAIN, ATTRIBUTION IS VERY
DIFFICULT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE CYBER WORLD.
>> Tucker: WILL THIS CONVINCE
ANYONE?
WILL MSNBC TOMORROW SAY COMING
IN ON WHAT, WE HAVE BEEN WRONG?
>> THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE
TIME FRAME I'VE BEEN SAYING,
BECAUSE NOBODY HAS SEEN ME ON TV
BEFORE TONIGHT THAT THERE WILL
BE SOME PEOPLE THAT AGREE AND
DISAGREE, BUT I WANT PEOPLE TO
SEE THAT AS MUCH OF THE
UNDERLYING DOCUMENT SO THAT
READERS CAN DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES WHETHER WE DID A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION AND WHAT
WE BASED OUR CONCLUSIONS ON.
LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE MAKE UP
THEIR OWN MIND.
THE REAL ISSUE IS THAT WE HAVE
ELECTION STARTING RIGHT NOW.
THE TEXAS PRIMARY LAST WEEK,
THIS IS A BIG DEAL THAT WE DO
NOT WANT THE RUSSIANS OR ANYONE
INTERFERING WITH THE ELECTION
PROCESS.
SO GETTING THESE CONCLUSIONS
OUT, WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT WILL GET US TO WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: THERE'S A LOT THAT
WE DO NOT KNOW, BUF CONFIRMED
THAT TO THE COLLUSION NARRATIVE
WAS A LIE.
>> THE DEMOCRATS HAVE ADDITIONAL
EVIDENCE, AND THEY MAKE
REFERENCE TO OVER AND OVER THAT
TODAY HAVE EVIDENCE TODAY IS HOW